[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
close your eyes
see with mine
[Music]
you are a top student but look at you
now you can't keep using your father's
disappearance as an excuse to act out is
that his work what's it about her dad he
wanted to touch the Stars imagine that
the aunt here wants to get to her other
hand as quickest option is to walk
across the street but it turns out a
straight line is not the shortest
distance between two points
not if you use fifth dimension it's
outside of the rules we know of time and
space so aunt arrives my hand
instantaneous so you follow space more
likely wrinkle it
we heard a cry out in the universe we
believe he is and we're here to help you
find it we are in search of warriors
warriors who serve the good and the
light in the universe you're kidding
do I look like I'm kidding a little I'm
not I'm not your father's trapped by an
evil energy it's too strong for our
light and the only one who can stop is
Hugh be a warrior
my love is always there even if you
can't see
[Music]
[Music]
my father always told me just survival
is never certain
and when there are no more leaders to
follow
you must become one
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I have this reoccurring dream I feel the
warmth of the Sun on my skin and the
comfort of arms around me and I want to
stay there forever but that would be
impossible I have a severe sensitivity
to sunlight doctor appointments became a
part of my routine it's not gonna fall
into remission in every year the risk
becomes more serious so I spend all my
time indoors behind special windows
sleeping during the day and staying up
all night and playing music every chance
I get
Hey what should I have said hey I'm
Katie Price I've watched outside my
window for the past 10 years that I've
been in love with you stalking you every
minute this is what Taylor Swift does
she has awkward interactions with boys
and then she just writes amazing songs
about it I don't understand how we've
never met I've probably skated by your
house every day on the way to practice
hey you wouldn't want to do something
sometime would you I'm really busy
during the day but I could be free at
night
[Music]
what does Katie price want to do there's
so many things I want to do are you
taking me in first live show
[Applause]
that was literally one of the best
things that are right I'll be a German
till the day I die
you coming
I am not comfortable with him not
knowing I'm going to I just need a
little longer being someone more than
just a disease this isn't something you
can just not tell me I'm so sorry but
we're not the couple who doesn't try
[Music]
[Music]
I believe my whole life to feel
[Music]
most of us ride this train every day
we not we say hello how much do we
really know about each other it's my
first time on a commuter train I'm sorry
if we met no I'm Joanna what what I
asked you to do something that could
prefer the effects an individual on this
train
I don't understand it's just one little
thing someone on this train does not
belong all you have to do is find them
why would I do it in the bathroom there
$75,000 and money is yours if you do
this one little thing
I thought this was hypothetical you have
until next stop to decide what kind of
person are you
Michael Michael McCauley
they're watching you
I am NOT gonna do this look outside
southeast corner
don't make me hurt someone you love it's
all over the news there's a witness
wasn't deep with the wrong kind of
people identify him
someone on this trains gonna kill him
what do you know
you have no idea who you're up against
I'm done playing games
[Music]
now everyone does
I'm not gonna let them hurt you
she's trying to set me up we have a
hostage situation take them out just
stop this train now
I asked you to do one little thing good
afternoon my Scotia as you know parole
and a privilege it's a mistake but it
happened and if I were to be released I
would um I would just want the simple
life I just want to hold on a job make
some friends
[Music]
yeah pay my bills even if this was
possible
it needs 20 people seven people why do
you need to do this cause that's what
I'm gonna how long would it take you to
make seven pieces of jewelry exoteric
how long if I told you didn't have to
live with your mother anymore it's me
the one it was quite what DNA yeah
which man named wall which real name
eight-ball what if we could make all
this go away there's a smell sorry okay
[Music]
I'm with my family I told you having a
garage let me tell you how big of John
knows I'm out
good job I'll be back before you know it
come with him this is mommy's very
special work trip
for three and a half weeks the met will
be hosting its annual ball we are going
to Robin not the ball itself on the neck
of Daphne Krueger valued at over a
hundred million dollars revenge it's a
twofer do not want a job in a job
[Music]
there's this can't we just go to this
debate to steal stuff yes
[Music]
is it genetic or the whole family like
this
literally
[Music]
let's go
medical marijuana is already a
multibillion-dollar industry the future
is this weed pill I'm still not sure
about this
look most people will tell you Buzz
Aldrin walked on the moon and even a
complete idiot will tell you Neil
Armstrong did it first and do you know
why he went first
there was additions hatch opening hiss
because he push Buzz Aldrin the [ __ ] out
of the way and seize history by the
ballsack
I'm satisfied
[Laughter]
look man you're in some deep water
Harold like bankruptcy dude then cash
pool no I'm saying you're poor poor
tomorrow you can apply to Mexico what we
want you to hand-deliver the weed pill
formula to the lab yes and I'm not
supposed to touch the minibar but I'm
going to do it you know I don't even
care anyone doing it what a [ __ ]
cry-baby
Harold I'm just gonna spit this out
gonna give a we sold a little product to
the cartels but when we cut them off
they got a little angry
I know one guy I've tracked down
dictators back to find a guy in middle
management what do they want so you
check the bull microchip good I need to
keep track II can't scare me
the tails of the big bag hotels no
thanks work not in Mexico that's Harold
Harold bingo
you really believe in God of course I
believe in God what kind of person does
not believe in God
I guess I kind of do but not things you
can just have to get better for you
trust me
I have good instincts
the most important thing a man can take
into combat it's a reason why during
this fight boy she mark my words
19 men attacked our country the 12 of
you will be the first ones to fight back
thus we're going in you know I love you
right I would be remiss if I did not say
to you even in success the odds of you
coming home you're a hundred percent sir
welcome
[Music]
why these men follow you you take me to
the Taliban I'll show you okay we take
horses he's serious
all right who's ridden before anyone
can't kill Spring Break goes free
hey this is we [ __ ]
[Music]
fifty-thousand okay to apply to us and
yours just an army of talk we've just
been handed the most important mission
in the free world
hold on our boys are gonna ride into
battle on horseback chances are we are
not gonna make it out of this one
equip now what happened back home it
happen again and again you know
each you got to make this decision
nothing I'd rather do
oh man thought you'd never ask
[Music]
where the hell do those come from
they got biggest guns first
I have a big gun cat the only way home
is winning
this is from the towers you carry that
with you it's weird you like to hang out
with animals more than people yeah
well animals get me a rescue George it
was 2 years old George never would have
survived on his own he definitely trusts
you
last night George was seven feet away
500 pounds George okay buddy
you're scared it's okay this morning his
nine feet pushing a thousand
what's happening to my friend
familiar with genetic editing changes
will be incredibly unpredictable
is he the only one oh you didn't know
about the 30-foot wolf hell of a day huh
science experiments falling from the sky
having George on that plane it's a big
mistake I think we'll be all right
let's go save the world
it's coming back to me
you have to evacuate Chicago George
didn't ask for this they're gonna put
him down
that's not happening
there's something in that River I was
just thinking the only thing that's
missing right now is the giant crocodile
[Music]
that is London
[Music]
[Music]